[Applause]
i think travis really got to come out
and say guys
i don't think you know how often people
pass out at concerts
and that's what i thought this was
somebody a little bit too intoxicated
right someone a little bit too high
right someone maybe just dehydrated
which is quite normal at concerts
happens all the time
but
if there's video of him looking and
seeing one of these people who ends up
dead
passed out and then deciding to continue
to concert yep
he's gonna get clobbered for this [ __ ]
yep he gotta say that this is normal he
has actually has to normalize this and
then other artists have to come out and
say bro we see people pass out all the
[ __ ] time yeah [ __ ] come and
get drunk they pass out yeah we don't
are not gonna assume every one of those
people that's passed out is dead yeah
am i wrong
now apparently people already asked him
like there's two things so one he
notices the ambulance which again isn't
refuting your point that like you know
he sees people pass all the time
there needs to be a better chain of
command from the emts to his management
to him bro and you heard the cop warned
him before he went on state before the
concert was like yo things have been
crazy it's [ __ ] coveted it's like all
this these things have been crazy just
be careful let's keep a line of
communication he said travis was
respectful before travis goes on stage
the chief says he went to travis and
personally was like hey i'm concerned
about the energy of the crowd
it's a little bit disconcerting travis
took that in
and then that [ __ ] happened
and
the
from what i understand travis's camp
hasn't refuted that the only thing they
said is the chief didn't say cancel the
show which the chief is like nah he
never said cancel the show he said
what are you telling me about that i
think just keep a [ __ ] keep an eye
out because your shows already get crazy
normally i understand i don't know that
[ __ ] but he's already chief is just
walking in there to take away
responsibility for himself sure but
you're also travis scott you've been
sued for inciting a riot you've pled
guilty for lollapalooza what i think was
also uh reckless endangerment
[ __ ] been paralyzing your shows
they claim like you should have some
kind of i like
at a certain point this was going to
happen i think
am i the one who thinks that kind of but
you can also like if you're in his
position just [ __ ]
yeah you are coming
that doesn't go to concerts and doesn't
enjoy fun yeah you saw travis scott once
and left 30 minutes in yeah yeah no
[ __ ]
dork
i'm going to be honest guys you should
have rushed this stage yeah i trampled
you would get trampled i didn't i left
travis scott five minutes in
wow
fire ass five minutes and then i was out
why
it's a song it's cool i'm out did he
have his shirt off
no that i would have stuck around for it
how'd you stay up the whole time of your
own wedding how'd you do that i had to
dude it was a
i'm the headliner wait would you have
left a little earlier
minor dude to be honest
right your way yeah
that's true yeah it's their winning yeah
yeah we're just there yeah well i'm the
feature actor but it's i have an
important i gotta stay there i gotta do
my time you gotta do your time if you
don't do your time it's a problem yeah
now apparently the stage operator came
up to travis scott during his
performance and told him what was going
on and asked him to address the crowd so
that they would have let they would let
emergency vehicles in now what did
travis say he said nah [ __ ] all that and
then went into the next song
allegedly according to stages i'm
telling you dawg the [ __ ] that's coming
out is not looking good
not looking good for him
the more that comes out the more you're
like yo this is a problem dog and you've
been had problems before and i get yo
his live show truly probably is the best
but that's a dangerous game you're
playing it's almost like he did on
purpose
almost as if it was a ritual oh we got
some conspiracy [ __ ] going is travis got
the devil
is he the devil he's literally he's
literally the devil oh my god bro talk
to us how does he spell his last name
s
what does a t look like a cross oh he
has two crosses what does that mean one
two positives make a negative another
yes so no problem
yeah
okay so how do you spell his name
without the crosses
c-s-c-o s-c-o yeah
skull
say i gotta do it all i'm saying i gotta
do it all you're not gonna help me a
little bit
come on bro people die yeah that's my
fault my fault take this seriously mark
all right okay you and your [ __ ]
conspiracy everybody gotta be the devil
with you you're such a boomer
okay
tell us tell us why travis scott is a
devil hey boomer hey boomer so this has
been alleged in uh across the internet
and in many of our youtube comments okay
that travis scott did this on purpose
again i don't i don't necessarily
endorse these ideas he got 50 000 people
into one space so he could kill eight
yeah kill eight which is a low death
rate if you're super low
sacrifice is always one person mad
people gather
you don't sacrifice the whole crowd
that's a good point now they're saying
they're covering it up though they said
more people die they just don't want you
to know about it oh my god and how are
they covering up like their parents
feeling about their loss
they uncrisis acted them oh yeah
my opposite of crisis gosh yeah
really yeah
this is crazy dude so multiple people
died that they're not uh talking about
yeah and
the specific reason
is so
they could spread
satan through houston texas yes
specifically houston or other places as
well i think specifically houston so
this is what one poster pointed out and
he says at the top let me just clarify i
highly doubt travis scott sacrificed
these people in some sort of ritual i'm
just pointing out what i observed and i
find interesting to spark a discussion
and it's a picture of travis scott a
massive bust of traffic travis scott
where people can walk in and out of yeah
and instead is the entrance into the
concert i imagine and his mouth is wide
open wide open and then below that
there's a picture it looks like it's
taking place i don't know medieval time
renaissance yeah so this is a painting
uh from dante's divine comedy also known
as dante's inferno
it's a form of symbolism that stands as
imagery for the gates of hell itself
holy [ __ ] so you'd be entering the gates
of hell through travis scott's mouth or
you'd be entering the gates of hell
through whatever this thing is in
dante's inferno yeah exactly
travis scott could be the devil dude all
right guys we gotta take a break from
this exclusive patreon clip because
this episode has been brought to you by
lucy lucy is out there man they are
killing the nicotine game without
killing you okay they got these capsule
pouches the lucy nicotine capsule
pouches they got a flavor bowl inside
each pouch that you can crush for extra
bursts of flavor new lucy nicotine
capsule pouches include coconut oil to
provide a soft fluffy texture
it enhances the flavor and doesn't dry
out your mouth remember they got no
tobacco in these things they come in two
strings four and eight milligrams and
three exclusive and delicious flavor
spearmint mango and cool cider okay it
is a cleaner alternative to tobacco damn
rice cigarettes all kinds of [ __ ] in
them lucy designed cleaner that's what
we're talking about over here and kind
of get you a little high
i gotta get you a little high buzz a
little
maybe buzz a little bit better let me
buzzed up on them pouches bro i like me
a nicotine
pouch
okay it's 20 21. don't compromise when
you're choosing your nicotine products
go with the newest tobacco-free options
from lucy okay
let me tell you this right now you could
go to lucy.co and use the promo code
flagrant to get 20 off your order of
lucy nicotine capsule pouches or any
other lucy products that's lucy.co and
use the promo code flagrant at checkouts
also i got to give this disclaimer
warning this product contains
non-tobacco nicotine nicotine is an
addictive chemical lucy.co
and be sure to use that promo code
flagrance okay
now let's get back to this exclusive
patreon clip you can get the whole
episode at patreon.com flagrant so
now if you keep scrolling miles exhibit
b
dude i feel like written house is
attorney right now oh i'm on fire
okay okay okay give me more give me more
all right so this is uh from travis
scott's latest oh my god
showing the eye in the palm of the hand
oh but we've seen this before classy or
cold imagery we've seen this before
where have we seen this before what is
that movie that we're looking at below
pan's labyrinth pans labyrinth yep
wow and if you keep scrolling beyond
that oh my god
this is the occult origin
of the eye in the palm of the hand oh my
god yo can i ask you a question it's
damning if it's not about travis
grabbing the devil then no what is the
occult
no one knows i know what occult is what
is occult it's like possum you can say
possum and opossums yeah exactly but
what oh what
yeah
i mean basically people just described
it cult as like any uh dark magic
underbelly of a society okay so it's
basically uh people operating with like
satanism witchcraft
[ __ ] is all one umbrella kind of yeah i
call it literally meaning like uh the
unknown or like well if he's just a
wizard
it could be a harry potter could be a
gizzard he could be
now if you'll keep scrolling to exhibit
c oh there's more exhibits dude there's
hundreds of exhibits there because this
is the truth
oh my god a true dystopia is here that's
what travis scott that's a picture of
stormy oh sorry
okay so he dropped dystopia the same day
that this happened
explain that andrew oh my god dude
explain there's a lot of evidence here
mark and i think you could be on to
something i think travis scott might be
part of the occult okay i think that he
might be a sane worshiper and i think
that he's using the devil's imagery to
probably deliver the devil's message
yeah this is a big problem yeah this is
a big problem as a christian male a
proud catholic protestant yes i feel
it is my duty to talk about this on our
platform we have a platform we have to
use rid
the devil
from houston rid the devil from spotify
i think he should be canceled from
i mean i think it should be cancelled
from concerts for the death of those
people for being the devil it's not even
a concert it's just a big gathering of
satan it's a ritual yeah i think that
all rituals should stop yeah
except ours
our rituals can continue but all other
rituals have stopped patreon every
friday now i feel like you're being
sarcastic okay yeah and apparently
yesterday no on november 5th the day of
the concert he came out with a song
escape plan
i thought that was a little crazy i saw
the timing there and i thought that was
a little bit crazy so you dropped a song
i would also drop a song
the day of my massive festival i think
that makes sense yeah the choice of the
song name
very unfortunate yeah
very unfortunate and it's probably too
late you've already done this marketing
everything's locked and loaded and going
for it i mean what is the song about
maybe he's just trying to reward his
real fans who listen to music the day it
comes out yeah here's how you stay away
from what's about to happen
yeah can you tell me what the song is
about is it about the battle the
bastards when jon snow gets stuck
it always goes back to game of
thrones anything that was such a good
episode anything serious without you
just going back to game immediately
that's the best episode it's a 10 year
old show about dragons we're trying to
talk about the devil all right it's a
serious conversation when you said that
it's a 10 year old show about dragons
i really just got goosebumps
all right goosebumps oh yeah yeah
oh okay guys
come on i'll be here all night all right
so he also in the cover of uh the
dystopia uh
the scopia tour i guess is the thing he
announced
when the end arrives it's really the
beginning
that's what he wrote
using occult symbols
and other i don't really know i'll be
honest i'm just not trying to piece this
together this one's not it but let me
hear this one this one where's the one
where he says put your middle fingers in
this is it
two minutes
he looks concerned genuinely
[Applause]
oh that actually looks like honest
concern compared to
he watches
[Music]
someone says don't do that bro
i mean this one slaps them
yo
[Applause]
i mean that that kind of turned up
he is the best live performer on earth
right like how lit did it feel when he
got from here
i was like this [ __ ] is fire bro i go
live i kind of wanted that beat to drop
son
i bet the people in the back had a great
time yes i bet they had a grand old time
oh yeah yay but that's that's [ __ ] up
man you feel uncomfortable there he knew
that there was something very wrong
somebody said no don't do that which
lets you know we're all like you know we
all are like oh you know what you do in
that situation somebody in that
situation was like what are you out of
your goddamn mind dude yeah yeah
i i don't know i kind of put him more in
like his management i think
okay like why aren't they stopping him
right like yeah i like i don't know he's
on stage he's doing his thing he's
focused on his performance like there
were people at the event that didn't
know that people had died like the
majority of people the majority of
people so here's where if you add up
everything that okay you're a performer
you're [ __ ] amped up whatever but you
saw that happen yeah then while you're
performing they tell you some [ __ ] is
going horribly wrong yeah and then you
keep going again like you already just
saw an ambulance yeah and that's where
i'm like at a certain point you gotta
stop the [ __ ] [ __ ] and be like yo
this is crazy we can't keep just
ignoring all this not like wildness you
know what i mean go
go
why are you laughing why are you
laughing bro
people have died andrew are you laughing
listen i don't have anything to say god
nothing
i have nothing to say you were just
saying something you were on a good rant
and then i just got a funny idea yeah
what was the idea go i was just waiting
for a part of your rant for you to say
something that i was gonna say it back
in like a mocking childish tone and then
you kept on saying more things about
people's lives being lost and i couldn't
do it so i just laughed myself and you
got the end of it that's how you got to
do it that's how you shut me down that's
smart shut me down by just saying like
important thoughtful yeah you just have
such a tell me i do you [ __ ] get this
really i got giddy you get like
predatory you're like a [ __ ]
blood in the water yeah listen um did he
not care that there was clearly
something going on at the show it seems
like it a little his feelings
was i want y'all to make the [ __ ]
ground move or something right yeah
i mean he didn't give a [ __ ] bruh no no
no no he did not give a [ __ ] now here's
the thing
he's got to come out and say this is
this happens so often in my shows i
didn't think anything of it if he comes
out he says this was unique yes i did
see an emt yes i did see an ambulance
and i was like that might be [ __ ] up
but then i kept going that's messed up
can't do it but if he comes out and said
hey it's very normal at concerts of 50
000 people that a few people are going
to pass out so i didn't want to stop the
whole show for something i see regularly
i think that he can be okay he needs
other people to say it though because
again this is our this guy that already
has been in trouble for this yeah
yeah the guy incites riots at his shows
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah he did
okay i'm going back to my trailer yeah
and now travis guys pulled off fortnite
i don't even understand that son i don't
know what fortnite i didn't expect you
to be honest yeah that's not like
performative [ __ ] that's like what yeah
he's pulled off i know you're struggling
with that [ __ ] now this thing is
about you're struggling so hard it's so
broken yeah huh she's so broke looks
like that girl in the stretcher
you guys are awful for laughing at that
that's awful you're awful for laughing
at that you're just leave it right there
oh listen to everything you say jesus
christ akash we're getting tired and
we're getting loose
we're getting tired and we're getting
loose okay um
no
the fortnite thing i don't understand
that seems performative yeah of course
it is it's
it's like a brand protection thing for
them yeah bro he makes a fortune he
throws events in the digital world and
so when we all have our little avatars
we'll bring we're going to go to
concerts but also
a game where you kill people yeah like i
wouldn't want to do a concert in
fortnite especially when you could just
go to astroworld and
[Laughter]
then you could
you don't have to worry about a loot box
or building any [ __ ] be like you want to
go to a concert go to a digital one
that's it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] that's so true
why does who the [ __ ] is fortnite think
they are yo [ __ ] fortnite why have you
ever played no dog guess what we're
saying [ __ ] fortnite that game's mad fun
it's mad fun but the fact that they're
gonna cancel travis scott
yeah they're trying to get protect their
money but do you think the kids would
really care
yeah i think it'd be a real bad look if
you hit travis scott
in a game where you kill people
a guy who actually kills people yeah
optically not he didn't kill but he
probably won at least how many probably
one he killed that concert
he killed that performance like he has
one eighth of responsibility the whole
thing i'll give him that you think
probably why
i don't know if he has some
responsibility i don't know what
percentage he has wait do you think
he'll get locked up or like you have to
pay a crazy fine no i don't think so
because there's also precedent for it
like all these other concerts where this
has happened yeah charlotte man was
listing them all off yeah so i think
they'll just probably follow that i
don't think he'll get go to prison but
he'll probably settle with the families
or some [ __ ] either him or like the
astral world llc whatever his business
is licensed what a girl sued drake
already oh of course yeah if drake's
anywhere near it you're gonna come from
yeah
is he gonna have to pay i think he can
be fine
we'll be fine guys on stage for 30
seconds what up people you just watch a
clip from our weekly patreon episode you
can support the flagrancy you can
support this unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's a top 10
patreon in the [ __ ] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.comflagrant2
all right peace